je prends quand même d'être arrivé à las
palmas parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
certains moments je me suis posé la
question de si je fais une escale ou pas
pour autant réglé mon problème d'énergie
j'ai plus à aller jusqu'au bout donc
pour moi c'est déjà bien d'être
jusqu'ici et après ben je sais pas
combien de temps ils ont devant moi les
autres mais celles qui sont arrivées
depuis ce matin shwan c'est ça donc on
verra on verra pour la suite
rien que du plaisir mais oui oui oui
après le cap une liste et alors on a eu
deux jours où c'était bien poney comme
on dit on a bien on a fait des bonnes
moyennes n'a je pense que sur la carte
où ça d'être pas mal
batum bien c'est là je pense que ça
pourrait faire j'ai autant tirer dessus
dans du vent fort en tout cas
c'était bien et après
et après j'ai encore des petites choses
à bricoler donc
non plutôt content quand même de cette
course j'ai appris j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses sur le bateau sur la façon de
le mener sur la façon de gérer aussi mal
géré aussi à bord et puis aussi de
repousser mes limites parce que c'est
que j'ai passées quasiment trente six
heures sans dormir pour essayer de
recharger mes batteries tant bien que
mal
j'ai quand même pu j'ai puisé loin dans
mes ressources et je trouve que j'ai
plutôt bien tenu sur à dire maintenant
est content d'arriver tu va préparer la
deuxième étape
exactement un peu par la 10e étape fait
un peu de boulot donc c'est bien qu'on
ait plusieurs semaines bsca